what's wrong with this teddy bear it's
not actually a toy bear but a camera
spyware can be found in hotels and
rented apartments in the most unexpected
places we've gathered three stories that
will shock you model Alexandra undone
found a hidden camera disguised as a
regular phone charger in an Airbnb
Dougie Hamilton and his girlfriend
wanted to spend a romantic weekend away
in a rented apartment in Toronto but
they discovered a hidden camera in a
digital clock by the sofa and Derek
Starnes and his wife found several
hidden cameras in smoke detectors above
the bed in a rented townhouse in Florida
it later turned out that the situation
was worse than they thought the owner of
the townhouse Wayne Nat filmed his
guests for two years and sold the videos
he was arrested be careful hidden
cameras are easy to get hold of and even
the sellers themselves disguise them but
remember filming without a person's
permission is illegal in almost all
countries of the world like this video
if you want us to tell you how to detect
a hidden camera in public places